let's start with the Divide between the
blue and red States it's obviously a big
theme around here and everyone's sort of
talking about just this this continued
sort of distancing between what's going
on if you live in a democrat-run state
and you live in a republican-run state
and Cali in Florida seem to be the two
best examples of that we've got some
info here on what's going on in
California right now this is from
theblaze.com Democrat Governor Gavin
Newsom forcefully criticized Walgreens
over its new plan to stop shipping and
selling abortion pills in some in some
states after 20 state attorney generals
sent a letter warning about the policy
Walgreens made the announcement on
Friday that it stores in 20 States would
not sell abortion pills we intend to be
a certified Pharmacy and we'll
distribute
mifepistron only in the jurisdictions
where it is legal and operationally
feasible read a statement from the
company pro-abortion Advocates said they
would boycott the company money over the
decision while pro-life Advocates
praised the decision Newsom issued a
fiery tweet on Monday excoriating the
company for caving to the demands from
20 state attorneys California won't be
doing business with Walgreens or any
company that cowers to the extremists
and puts women's lives at risk we're
done now first off it's a little unclear
to me if Gavin Newsom knows what those
pills actually do because some of those
babies do turn out to be women but again
what is a woman
my personal take on this it's like if
the if the states don't want the
abortion pills there and Walgreens wants
to abide by that that's fine Walgreens
isn't stopping anything from happening
in Cali but this is kind of what Newsome
does isn't it Sarah yeah you know it's
interesting because in that statement
that he gave he calls Walgreens he says
that they're capitulating to extremists
they're following the law so I mean I I
would say the extremist is the one who
is demanding that a private company not
follow the law break the law in other
states in which Newsom has no pardon
just so that he can say uh hey we're
doing something we're helping women and
so it's just fascinating to see him you
know change use the the language to just
change the entire narrative I don't
think it's going to work and by the way
I would like to just bring up on the
issue of this abortion pill
um which is what he's advocating that
they allow by mail this is a really
dangerous thing I mean you've got
multiple studies that show uh that there
that they women are more at risk for
severe side effects they've got
hemorrhaging they're more at risk for
the need for follow-up surgery uh even
death and so by making this more
available to women by mail rather than
under a doctor's care he's saying that
this is about women but if he wanted it
to be about women why would he put them
more at risk I mean it just it blows my
mind that he's able to use this
narrative that Walgreens is the one
that's doing something wrong here right
and again he's just or Walgreens is just
going by what the state decisions are
this is not going to they're following
the law if you'd like more sane takes on
our insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
roundtables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell